bonjour à tous vous allez pouvoir suivre
dans un instant l'audition de Pascal
lami par la commission des affaires
économiques du Sénat alors Pascal lami a
été longtemps collaborateur de Jacques
Delor il a été pendant 5 ans
commissairire européen et pendant 10 ans
directeur général de l'OMC
l'organisation mondiale du commerce
aujourd'hui il est président d'honneur
du laboratoire d'idée notre Europe
institut Jacques Delor et c'est à ce
titre qu'il est d'ailleurs entendu ce
matin là par la commission des affaires
économiques l'Europe c'est un sujet de
prédilection pour Pascal lami qui est
également investi dans de nombreux
autres think tank tous très favorables à
l'intégration européenne cette année
enfin il a été l'auteur d'un livre quand
la France s'éveillera un livre qui
présente toutes les pot alité de la
France vue du monde voilà tout de suite
donc direction la salle clémenenceau
pour cette audition de Pascal Lam et on
se retrouve juste après vos fonctions
votre position vos compétences largement
reconnues font de vous un observateur
privilégié de la situation économique et
sociale de la France et de l'Europe car
la connaissance fine de ce qui se fait
ailleurs dans le monde vous permet de
voir sans doute autrement ce qui se fait
ici c'est ce regard à la fois
distancier qui nous intéresse tout
particulièrement vous venez d'ailleurs
de publier un ouvrage dans le titre
exprime l'ambivalence de la situation de
notre
pays de votre point de vue quand la
France s'éveillera ça nous rappelle un
autre
titre ce titre sonne à la fois comme un
constat sévère puisque Sion s'éveille
c'est bien qu'on était endormi ou
assoupi ou à tout le moins suffisamment
mobilisé en même temps il exprime aussi
un certain optimisme quant à l'avenir de
notre économie et la force de nos atouts
vous dénoncez dans cet ouvrage la
tendance de certains en Europe et en
France à céder à ce que vous appelez la
délectation délectation
morosa j'ignore s'il règne en Europe une
morosité ambiante un peu morvide mais il
existe un certain nombre d'indicateurs
objectif qui montre que tout ne va pas
pour le mieux croissance en berne
chômage élevé accroissement de la
pauvreté accroissement des inégalités
inversion de la tendance historique à la
réduction donc de ces inégalités de
revenus de patrimoine au sein de nos
sociétés montter du vote d'extrême
droite dans nombre de pays européens à
commencé par le nôtre nous souhaitons
donc vous entendre sur votre
diagnosticque de la situation économique
de l'Europe et et si possible de la
France y a-t-il selon vous des facteurs
de blocage de la croissance européenne
quel le regard poré vous sur les
politiques économiques menées en Europe
et en France tout ça c'est un tout
agitons sur les bons leviers qu'il soi
structurel ou
conjoncturel autrement dit se
mobiliseant sur les bons enjeux et les
bonnes priorités
et dernier point que sur lequel je
souhaiterais avoir votre
sentiment après avoir lu d'ailleurs un
interview de
vous j'ai lu
votre analyse sur les barrières non
tarifaires qui sont du domaine des
valeurs et de la
précaution ce principe qui qui devrait
gérer les risques et non pas être
interprété comme une assurance du risque
zéro ceci bien entendu en vue des
négociations qui sont en cours entre les
États-Unis et l'Europe et les barrières
non tarifffaires sont évidemment en
particulier je pense aux normes que
pourraiit nous imposer les États-Unis
par rapport à nos pratiques concernant
la santé et l'environnement en Europe
voilà je vous laisse la parole et je
pense qu'après votre intervention il y
aura des échanges avec les sénateurs et
sénatrices merci merci mon
Président merci pour cette invitation en
en préparant cette
discussion j'ai réalisé que c'était la
première fois depuis 40
ans que j'apparaissais dans cette
maison libre de toute contrainte
institutionnelle et donc et donc avec
une
parole qui est ma seule responsabilité
et qui n'engage aucune des institutions
auxquelles j'ai appartenu dans lesqueles
j'ai travaillé que parfois j'ai dirigé
euh dans la République française euh
dans l'Union européenne ou au niveau
international et pour tout dire ça fait
drôle mais c'est pas désagréable enfin
j'espère que c'est un point de vue que
vous partagerez euh je vais très
brièvement introduire la discussion
puisque je ne suis plus porteur d'une
doctrine institutionnelle d'un discours
institutionnel euh en en répondant aux
deux questions que vous venez de
poser d'abord sur le les perspectives de
l'économie européenne et ensuite sur
cette affaire de traité transatlantique
dont la négociation a commencé au mois
de juin de l'année
dernière pas anormal à la veille
d'élections européennes qu'on
s'intéresse à ce sujet enfin je dirais
et je sais que cette maison de de ce
point de vue a toujours été une
exception
euh le Sénat a toujours et c'est mon
expérience et je vous ai donner une
indication de la durée de cette
expérience a toujours manifesté un
intérêt particulier pour les questions
européennes euh il y a un savoir-faire
une approche qui je le dois dire est
rare dans nos institutions et que j'ai
toujours en tout cas éprouvé comme un
soutien à l'intégration européenne même
si évidemment il peut y avoir des
nuances politiques ici ou là alors si on
prend la longue vue pour regarder non
pas sur le passé mais sur l'avenir en
gros les 10 années qui
viennent l'économie mondiale
c'est 6 % de
croissance pour les pays en
développement émergent c'est 3 % de
croissance pour les États-Unis et c'est
1 et demi de croissance pour l'Europe
toute chose égal par
ailleurs autrement dit nos perspectives
à moyen long terme c'est la moitié de la
croissance américaine qui est elle même
la moitié de celle des pays en
développement cette hiérarchie est le
produit de
force qui sont celles qui sont les
grands
facteurs qui déterminent la croissance
conomique dans le monde globalisé qui
est le nottre et en très
gros pourquoi ce 1 et demi%
européen très
simplement c'est la
somme de 2 % de productivité globale des
facteurs par an qui est ce que nous
avons connu à peu près au cours des 10
dernières années disons c'est le haut de
la fourchette de la la
prévision Mo ins 0,5 % qui est la baisse
annuelle tendantielle de la population
active en
Europe donc la production
européenne la dynamique de production
européenne c'est la productivité globale
des facteurs plus la croissance des
facteurs sauf qu'il y a un des facteurs
qui décroit qui est la population
active et ce 2 % de
productivité projection moyenne et
longue je je le répète et le haut de la
fourchette donc ce 15 % toute chose égal
par ailleurs c'est le haut de la
fourchette si la
productivité est à 1 1/% au lieu de 2 %
le taux de croissance à moyen terme de
l'Union européenne c'est 1
% c'est évidemment une perspective assez
sombre toute chose égale par
ailleurs notamment parce
que le
modèle de civilisation européenne ce
qu'on appelle entre nous Européens ce
modèle d'économie sociale de marché
n'est pas seulement une économie de
marché c'est économie sociale de marché
qui se distingue d'autres modèles
disponibles sur la planète par un taux
de
redistribution au titre du social que ce
soit l'éducation que ce soit la santé
que ce soit les retraites que ce soit le
logement euh nos pays européens euh
dépense beaucoup en redistribution c'est
c'est ce fameux chiffre que Madame
Merkel cite depuis 2 ans sur toutes les
tribunes l'Europe c'est 7 % de la
population mondiale 20 % de la
production mondiale et 50 % des dépenses
de sécurité sociale dans le
monde ce qui est une manière de dire que
c'est
beaucoup on peut certains le feront
trouver que c'est trop on peut aussi ce
qui est mon cas trouver que c'est au
fond ce qui fait notre vraie identité
européenne dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
et de demain à condition d'accepter
que ce n'est soutenable comme modèle
qu'avec une croissance qui permet de le
nourrir quand vous avez une grosse
partie de votre économie qui fait
l'objet d'une redistribution
inévitablement le débat politique est
toujours assez vif sur les condition de
ce partage c'est un problème que les
Américains par exemple n'ont pas
vraiment comp tenu de de leur système
économique et social chez nous
naturellement
identitairement si je puis dire cette
question est importante et mon sentiment
pour ce qu'il vaut c'est que en gros en
dessous de 2
% le système se crispe au-dessus de 2 %
le système retrouve si je puis dire une
respiration normale on peut discuter
hein tout ça est très schématique mais
je dis cela parce que ce problème d'une
faible croissance européenne pour autant
qu'on puisse la prévoir et tout chose
égal par ailleurs n'est pas seulement un
problème économique c'est pas seulement
un problème conjoncturel c'est pas
seulement un problème de chômage et nous
savons que nous avons un taux de chômage
très important en moyenne en Europe
aujourd'hui même s'il est distribué de
manière un peu différente selon les pays
c'est ça va plus loin hein c'est un
problème en quelque sorte
de nature
identitaire si nous ne trouvons pas un
chemin de croissance de l'ordre 2 %
alors nos peuples dans leur
identité seront insatisfaits avec les
conséquences que cela
produit faiblesse et force en très très
gros de l'Union européenne dans le monde
contemporain on vient d'identifier la
première et la principale des faiblesses
qui est la démographie euh nous sommes
le seul continent qui vieillit à ce
point en Europe dans les 10 ou 20 années
qui viennent nous seront d'ailleurs
suivis par la Chine dans les décennies
qui suivent qui paieront à ce moment-là
cette
politique
incroyablement
intrusive dans la nature humaine qui est
la
politique d'un enfant par ménage je
iniste pas là-dessus ces perspectives
sont connues deuxème faiblesse
structurelle dans le jeu des chaises
musical de la répartition des ressources
énergétiques l'Europe a été mal dotée
euh nous sommes de très très gros
importateurs d'énergie et ceci nous met
en quelque sorte en situation de
dépendance à la fois
stratégique mais aussi du point de vue
de la compétitivité dans la mesure où
euh les produits productur d'énergie ont
tendance à utiliser l'énergie la moins
chère chez eux et exporter une énergie
légèrement plus chère et c'est
évidemment encore plus vrai depuis la
révolution du gazochiste aux États-Unis
qui reste dans les 10 années
àenir notre concurrent principal trè a
de faiblesse qui elle n'est pas
structurelle mais qui est
malheureusement installée pour l'instant
qui est euh le le rétrécissement de la
part de la frontière technologique qui
est occupé par les Européens dans le
monde
d'aujourd'huiin il y a 20 ou 30 ans
l'Europe occupait disons à peu près 30 %
de la frontière technologique les
Américains entre 40 et 50 % euh
aujourd'hui si on regarde ce qui se
passe dans les technologies de
l'information dans les nanotechnologies
dans les biotechnologies
de manière très approximative la part
que l'Europe occupe dans cette frontière
est de l'ordre de 15 maximum 20 % les
États-Unis sont probablement à 60 % et
un certain nombre de pays émergents
commence à occuper si je peux dire les
10 ou 15
% qu'il sur lesquels il pénètrent au fur
et à mesure que leur niveau
d'édocation d'élaboration de la
propriété intellectuelle de production
d'ingénieur s'élève
ça n'est pas irrémédiable mais c'est une
tendance lourde dont nous devons bien
être conscient parce
que les produits de demain ce qui fera
l'objet de l'activité économique de ce
que les consommateurs rechercheront de
ce que les producteurs de biens et de
services devront satisfaire ce sont des
choses de plus en plus immatérielles
dans lequel si je puis dire de manière
vulgaire le contenu en jus de cervel
devient de plus en plus important et le
contenu en huile de coude de moins en
moins important et ceci évidemment est
un enjeu crucial du point de vue des
systèmes de
formation
dernier facteur de faiblesse qui elle
aussi n'est pas structurel mais qui est
là c'est la
relative faible productivité du secteur
des services en Europe si vous comparez
par exemple la productivité de
l'économie américaine et de l'économie
européenne les Américains jouissent d'un
avantage comparatif important en matière
de prix des services parce qu'ils ont un
marché intérieur des services à la
hauteur d'une population de consommateur
qui est bien moins important que la
nôtre mais leur marché de service est un
marché intérieur qu' alors que nous
savons qu'au niveau européen ça n'est
fait aujourd'hui que à quelque chose de
l'ordre de 30 à 40 % et encore alors que
c'est fait disons à de l'ordre de 80 à
90 % dans les biens ceci va plus loin
que la considération du seul secteur des
services dans la mesure où l'économie
moderne intègre de manière de plus en
plus considérable l'industrie et les
services c'est très difficile dans le
monde d'aujourd'hui et à forcerie dans
le monde de demain de faire une
frontière entre ce qui est de
l'industrie ce qui est des services et
si vous regardez la valeur ajoutée de
beaucoup d'objets disons d'artefacts qui
ressemblent à des produits industriels
aujourd'hui en réalité vous apercevez
que l'essentiel de la valeur ajoutée ce
sont des services hein si si pr vre
tablette ou le téléphone mobile avec
lequel Marie Noël est en train de
consulter internet et bien si on prend
ce petit objet ça ressemble ça ressemble
à un produit industriel hein une usine
qui a produit ça simplement là-dedans il
y a 5 % de valeur ajoutée industrielle
qui est le truc en plastique
éventuellement en aluminium il y a la
valeur des terres rares qu' on été
manipuler pour faire les puces qu'il y a
là-dedans et le reste c'est tout du jus
de cervel hein c'est des programmes
c'est des brevets c'est du design c'est
de la
distribution face à ça où sont les
forces euh il y a une force
essentielle qui est celle euh que nous
devons nous Européens exploiter
davantage euh qui est notre masse notre
taille qui est la la la largeur et la
profondeur et la profondeur de notre
marché que ce soit dans la concurrence
internationale ou que ce soit dans
l'obtention des progrès de productivité
qui sont disponibles hein euh alors si
je regarde encore une fois à un niveau
très planétaire cette masse l'Europe
l'utilise
correctement dans ce qui est la gestion
de la concurrence internationale he au
cours des dernières années les pars de
marché international de l'Europe n'ont
pratiquement pas bougé alors que les
États-Unis et celle des États-Unis et du
Japon se sont très nettement
effrité et donc globalement globalement
la gestion par l'Europe de sa relation
avec l'économie internationale la mesure
dont elle respire avec cette économie en
terme d'exportation et d'importation au
niveau européen et de bonne
qualité par contre c'est vrai que comme
je dit il y a un problème de
productivité qui est largement lié au
marché intérieur des services donc ceci
en quelque sorte nous
donne et de manière très schématique
nous donne une espèce de feuille de
route hein dans ces cas-là il faut
combler ses faiblesses et exploiter ses
atouts combler la faiblesse démocratique
euh
démographique c'est pas commode euh on
connaît sous la solution historique hein
elle est parfaitement disponible euh
c'est l'immigration c'est toujours comme
ça que ça s'est passé dans l'histoire à
ceci près que nous savons que ça se
heurte à des rétisenceces dont certaines
sont culturelles et d'autres d'autres de
nature plus politique euh c'est
évidemment c'est évidemment la solution
sur le plan théorique euh reste
effectivement mesurer la distance qu'il
y a parfois entre la théorie et la
faisabilité politique mais il faudra de
toute
façon il faudra de toute façon que
l'Europe importe de la force de travail
à terme de 10 ou 20 ans si elle veut
maintenir le modèle d'économie sociale
de marché qui est le sien en matière
d'énergie on sait comment disons sur le
plan théorique remédier à un certain
nombre de faiblesse de l'Europe ça
s'appelle la transition énergétique ça
s'appelle des économies renouvelables ça
s'appelle l'efficacité énergétique c'est
d'ailleurs une des raisons pour
lesquelles l'Europe si je puis dire est
depuis longtemps à la pointe
de deun certain nombre de de d'actions
international en matière de
d'environnement de changement climatique
d'émission de gaz à effercre et
d'économie d'énergie mais nous savons
aussi que il reste énormément à faire
tant si je puis dire la notion de
politique énergétique commune européenne
est encore très très fumeuse étant
disons chacun des modèles nationaux que
ce soit le recours aux énergies fossil
par rapport au renouvelables que ce soit
les problèmes de gestion des prix de
cette énergie que ce soit les problèmes
de gestion de l'augmentation de
l'efficacité énergétique sont encore sur
un spectre très très différent je
n'insiste pas sur ce point qui est
évident sur la frontière
technologique là aussi la solution
théorique est çaz bien connu hein il
faut il faut
investir dans l'avenir et il faut
investir dans l'avenir avec des tickets
de plus en plus gros tout en sachant que
seulement une partie du ticket investi
est porteur de découverte d'innovation
de développement sur les marchés mais
que vous regardiez l'industrie
pharmaceutique que vous regardiez les
industries
de de l'industries de l'information que
ce soit tout ce qui est autour de
l'économie vgétale on voit bien que il
n'y a plus pratiquement au niveau de la
production final il n'y a plus que des
éléphants qui ont bâti leur succès sur
des visions des recherches mais avec des
mises en capitaux pour ce qui est du
système de production considérable et
donc ça veut dire que c'est aussi un
domaine où en théorie nous devrions nous
pourrions bénéficier de notre fait
d'échelle à condition de concentrer
l'excellence et de ne pas la disperser
et nous savons tous que disons dans
l'entreprise d'intégration européenne
notamment sur les programmes de
recherche il y a quand même une certaine
tendance à faire plaisir à tout le monde
et donc à éparpierer un peu les moyens
alors qu'en réalité il faudra les
consencrer ce qui suppose une volonté
politique particulièrement
déterminée sur les force j'en ai parlé
c'est essentiellement le marché
intérieur dans dans les services qui
pourrait être source de productivité et
donc à terme
d'emploi nous savons tous qu'à court
terme la productivité c'est du
changement d'emploi nous savons tous
qu'à long terme la productivité c'est de
l'emploi et comme par hasard d'ailleurs
ce sont les économies les plus
productives et les plus compétitive qui
ont le taux de chômage le plus bas je
n'insiste pas sur ce point qui est
parfois chez nous un peu perdu
de donc là je me suis limité au champ
européen bien
entendu si on si on regarde par exemple
les problèmes que la France a affronté
hélas depuis très longtemps en matière
de équip de finances publiques en
matière de chômage de masse en matière
d'érosion de la
compétitivité les 2 tiers
euh des solutions à ces questions ne
sont pas d'ordre européen elles sont
d'ordre national la preuve d'ailleurs
c'est qu'à l'intérieur du même cadre
avec la même politique commerciale
commune avec les mêmes institutions avec
la même politique macro-économique pour
autant que est une il y a des
performances très très différentes à la
fois sur les finances publiques sur le
chômage et sur la compétitivité donc ça
ça nous dit que quand même
l'essentiel ça se passe au niveau
domestique au niveau national mais
évidemment l'échelon européen peut-être
important en tant que catalyseur et en
tant que niveau pertinent pour des
économies d'échelle qui s'agit des
investissements dans les infrastructures
qui s'agisse de la Recherche
Développement qui s'agisse même de
programmes comme ceux qui sont apparus
au cours des dernières années
pour lutter contre le chômage de jeunes
avec des systèmes d'apprentissage de
type
erasmous le tout étant effectivement une
question de
dosage l'Europe passe par une phase de
désendettement qui à mon avis était
nécessaire je nappelle pas cela de
l'austérité j'appelle ça du
désendettement mais il est vrai aussi
que nous ne faisons pas ensemble assez
d'investissement dans ce que dans ce qui
constitue les programmes d'avenir IR et
je pense que ça c'est vraiment une
question majeure pour la prochaine
législature
européenne après que les électeurs
européens auront déterminé le rapport
des forces politiques au Parlement
européen et donc dans une certaine
mesure et moyennant les discussions
nécessaires entre le Conseil européen et
le Parlement européen la composition de
la commission
européenne donc voilà pour ce qui est de
votre première question monsieur
président
sur le traité
transatlantique en un mot et on pourra y
revenir en fonction de vos
questions ce cette négociation s'inscrit
dans un
basculement considérable
historique à la fois du commerce
international et de la régulation du
commerce international hein si vous
voulez le la régulation du commerce
international a pour objet
euh de réduire ou d'éliminer les
obstacles aux échanges pour autant qu'il
soit illégitime ce qui suppose une
définition consensuelle de ce que ça
veut dire d'illégitime mais
disons le le la base idéologique
d'ailleurs celle ciment idéologique des
des membres de l'UMC c'est que en gros
l'ouverture des échanges ça marche parce
que ça permet à chacun de faire
davantage de ce en quoi il où est bon et
de faire faire par les autres ce que là
où ils sont bons vieille théorie toute
simple
ricardienne qui peut faire l'objet de
modèle économique très compliqué mais
disons qui se comprend assez bien c'est
ça c'est l'efficience qui fait de la
croissance et donc potentiellement de la
productivité j'ai consacré d'ailleurs à
ce sujet un petit livre mais qui est en
anglais que j'ai publié l'anne dernière
à Cambridge University Press qui fait le
tour de la question ceux d'entre vous
qui veut l'apofondir savent que je suis
toujours disponible j'ai passé trop de
temps de ma vie dans ce dans ce métier
euh pour ne pas il a en avoir garder
petite expérience et en tout cas une
certaine
affection réduire les obstacles aux
échanges depuis en gros 2
millénaires depuis que le le premier
traité de commerce a été signé entre le
roi de Crète et le pharaon d'Égypte ça
consistait à réduire des mesure qui
étaient des obstacles à l'échange et
dont l'objet était de protéger les
producteurs nationaux de la concurrence
étrangère pour diverses raisons type
droit de
Douine ce monde est en train de mourir
se terminer il est comme comme ces comme
ces étoiles dont on perçoit encore la
lumière non pas parce que elles existent
elles sont mortes maisons la lumière met
un certain temps à arriver jusqu'à nos
yeux
et les droits douan en gros c'est ça
historiquement pourquoi tout simplement
parce que la technologie la
globalisation cette phase là de
globalisation conduit à une
multilocalisation des processus de
production au fond on
est j'ai développé cette doctrine quand
j'étais directeur général de l'OMC on
est dans une époque où les chaudes ne
sont plus made in France made in Germany
made in Japan made in China made World
60 % du commerce international sont des
composants ou des pièces détachées le
contenu en importation des exportations
moyens dans le monde était 20 % il y a
20 ans c'est 40 % aujourd'hui ce sera 60
% dans 20 ans hein et donc cette
interpénétration qui au fond est en
train de détruire la notion de frontière
de ce point de vue
euh suit son cours et et pour cette
raison c'est c'est bien sûr qu'il y a
des disciplines que compris celle de
l'OMC ont permis de de passer en tout
cas de ne
pas céder à à des tentation à des
pulsions et donc à pas produire de choc
protectionniste dire le commerce
international a remarquablement résisté
à la crise économique mais c'est pas ça
l'essentiel l'essentiel c'est qu'à
partir du moment où plus de la moitié
euh de vos exportations dépendent de
votre contenu en importation shooter
dans vos importations ça veut dire euh
démolir la compétitivité de vos
exportations c'est aussi simple que cela
donc ce monde-là est en train de se
terminer est-ce que pour autant euh le
commerce est libre non euh parce que euh
il subsiste et se multiplie d'autres
obstacles au commerce d'une autre nature
c'est ce que vous appeliez à juste titre
les barrières non tarifffaires euh qui
sont
le produit de réglementation nationale
souvent européenne dans le cas
européen qui sont destinés à protéger
non pas le producteur de la concurrence
étrangère mais le consommateur de risque
divers et qui donc tourne autour de la
notion de
précaution qui établissent et
administrent un niveau de précaution qui
s'agisse de la sécurité des aliment des
des critères de crash test pour les
voitures de la sécurité des jouets des
briquets de la protection des données
privées du régime prudentiel des banques
et des assurances et j'en
passe ces mesures se multiplient dans le
monde au fur et à mesure que disons le
progrès et le développement permet à des
femmes et à des hommes de se préoccuper
d'autres chose que savoir si eux ou
leurs enfants vont manger le lendemain
ce qui est finalement une assez bonne
nouvelle en intéresse à des choses qui
sont de l'ordre des
valeurs euh simplement se faisant on
juxtapose des échelles de valeur qui
sont parfois très différentes euh et
donc la question de l'avenir en terme de
régulation de l'échange international ça
n'est plus de réduire ou d'éliminer ces
obstacles mêmees personne ne va
euh changer euh son standard de maximum
de résidus de pesticides dans les fleurs
coupées pour favoriser le commerce
international aucun Parlement ne
ratifiera
ça et donc le le jeu n'est plus de
d'éliminer ces obstacles il est
d'éliminer ce qui fait problème
c'est-à-dire la différence entre ces
obstacle ça c'est un exercice évidemment
beaucoup plus compliqué qui est de ordre
la convergence
réglementaire concept d'ailleurs que les
que les Européens connaissent assez bien
parce que c'est au fond ce qui a fait la
différence entre le marché commun
d'avant 92 et le marché intérieur
d'après 92 quelle est la différence
c'est en gros de la convergen
réglementaire sur les normes et les
standards c'est évidemment encore une
fois un enjeu très très différent il est
en parti encadré par les règles de l'OMC
et notamment par l'accord sur les
barrières techniques au commerce et par
l'accord sur les mesures sanitaires
phosanitaire mais il encadré que dans
les principes les les organisations les
organes de régulation aussi bien au
niveau national qu'au niveau
international quand il y en a qui sont
responsables de ces normes de ces
standards ne sont pas des organes
commerciaux hein ce sont des organes
parfois scientifiques parfois technique
mais le l'idée parmi c'est régulateurs
euh dont l'objectif est de et la
protection et la
précaution l'idée que ils vont négocier
entre eux des standards communs que ce
soit euh pour les harmoniser ou que ce
soit pour en accepter la reconnaissance
mutuelle est une idée assez compliquée
et ça c'est l'objet de ce traité
transatlantique si vous regardez les
échanges euro-américains c'est à peu
près 1000 milliards de dollars par an
euh la partie marchandise bien de ce
commerce qui est soumis à les droits de
douanes est assez faible disons le droit
de douane moyen entre les États-Unis et
l'Europe aujourd'hui c'est de l'ordre de
2 2 et5 % hein donc l'ouverture de
l'échange transatlantique qui fait du
sens du point de vue de des gains
d'efficience c'est
80 % de la convergence réglementaire
hein ça consiste à faire en sorte que
les voitures américaines et les voitures
européennes et les mêmes standards de
sécurité que les crash tests soient
sinon identiques du moins équivalents
que on se mette d'accord sur la norme de
déchlorination euh des poulets parce
qu'on sait bien qu'il faut laver les
poulets quand on produit des dans des
usines à poulet il va falloir se mettre
d'accord sur les questions de protection
des données privées tout sujets qui sont
pour un certain nombre d'entre eux très
sensibles très délicats parce que par
que la manière dont vous percevez le
risque et la manière dont vous gérez la
précaution est assez étroitement
corrélée avec une échelle de valeur un
risque c'est quoi c'est quelque chose si
ça se produit c'est moins bien que si ça
se produit pas il y a tout de suite du
bien et du mal dans la symbolique qui
s'exerce en gestion de la
précaution et et ça c'est je crois une
question majeure
et mon sentiment et là je je m'exprimais
avec précaution pour pour que mes propos
ne provoqu pas de problème mon sentiment
c'est que cette négociation a été
lancée comme une négociation
classique au
fond il y a la chose et il y a le nom on
lui a donné un nom on l'a associé à un
narratif qui ressemble à un accord
classique comme l'Union européenne en a
signé avec la Corée
avec avec le Canada récemment et comme
les États-Unis en on signé avec les
psamérique latine bon or c'est un animal
de nature différente et et la différence
de cette nature à mon avis mériterait
d'être mieux expliqué mieux souligné ne
serait-ce ne serait-ce que pour répondre
à des questions légitim euh qui viennent
d'ailleurs des deux côtés comme par
hasard euh et qui consiste à se demander
si une telle convergence va se
faire au détriment de la précaution il
peut y avoir des soupçons légitimes et
notamment en Europe que finalement
l'Europe est un continent très
précautionneux que les États-Unis sont
un continent beaucoup
plus beaucoup
plus habitué au risque et que donc ceci
va se faire au détriment d'un niveau de
précaution auqu disons les Européens
tiennent pour des raisons
identitaires je crois qu'il faut il faut
regarder ça avec un peu de recul il y a
des tas d'endroits et j'en connais de
secteurs techniqu où la précaution
américaine est supérieure à la
précaution
européenne prendre qu'un exemple il y a
pas de voiture diesel aux États-Unis il
y a des camions diesel parce que le
syndicat des camionneurs est
suffisamment fort pour ça pour les
camions mais pas pour les voitures et
pourquoi parce que c'est pas bon pour
l'environnement historiquement ce sont
les Américains qui ont inventé le le
principe de précaution dans les années
70 avec le cleinerct alors que à
l'époque l'Europe était sur le logiciel
po payer qui est exactement le contraire
de la précaution auquel nous sommes
venus après et donc ça c'est un enjeu
important mon sentiment
personnel c'est que cette négociation
qui sera
longue
complexe qui donne à lieu à beaucoup de
débats et il faut compte tenu de la
sensibilité des sujets abordés qu'elle
donne mieux à débat et à transparence
mon sentiment c'est qu'à la fin ça
s'alignera sur le niveau de précaution
le plus élevé de chacun des deux
côtés je ne vois pas personnellement
c'est mon expérience de négociateur
commercial dans ces domaines même si ce
sont des domaines qui ont été moins
négociés que les obstacles précédents je
pense que c'est comme ça que ça
terminera simplement c'est très
difficile tactiquement quand on démarre
une
négociation de dire bon bah finalement
ça va être simple on va prendre le
niveau de précaution le plus élevé des
deux
côtés sans comme ça rentrer dans la
technique parce que qu'est-ce que ça
veut dire dans la pharmacie dans la
chimie dans l'automobile dans
l'agroalimentaire ce serait fond la
manière la plus simple de d'obtenir
l'objectif mais on sent bien que pour
des raisons tactiques et politiques
cette suggestion est un peu utopique
mais je crois que c'est dans cet esprit
là qu'il faut se placer j'en termine là
pour laisser autant de place que
possible à vos
questions
merci et donc Monsieur
vugrenard Merci monsieur le
Président je voulais vous interroger
monsieur l'ami sur les les quelques
points que vous avez
abordés également sur les quelques
déclarations que vous avez faites ces
dernières semaines mais venons-en
d'abord au point que vous avez abordé
notamment sur les les différences entre
le la France l'Europe et le reste du
monde en quelque sorte vous avez indiqué
que la croissance des pays émergents
dans les années à venir elle est de 6 %
ça à 3 % en Europe à 1 demi %. les
questions de productivité certes sont à
prendre considération elles sont
importantes de la même
manière les
investissements dans le cadre de la
recherche et d'innovation on voit
combien ils sont différents en France
avec le reste de l'Europe et encore plus
avec les pays émergents et les
États-Unis une question qui n'a pas été
abordée c'est les questions aussi
monétaires il nous est arrivé
d'auditionner Louis Galois lorsqu'il
avait un responsabilité EADS et
fréquemment il nous disait la différence
de parité entre le dollar et l'euro nous
pose manifestement des problèmes
concurrentiels qui sont qui sont
importants ne pensez-vous pas que la
Banque centrale
européenne devrait être plus audacieuse
en matière de politique monétaire pour
faire diminuer la parité de l'euro face
au
dollar une note récente de de de
Bercy indique les avantages de la
dévaluation de l'euro si l'euro était
dévalué de 10 % ça pourrait entraîner la
première année une augmentation du
produit intérieur brut de notre pays de
0,6 % au bout de la 3e année 1,2 % avec
les conséquences au niveau de l'emploi
qui serait chiffré à 30000 emplois
supplémentaires la première année 150000
la 3e année les chiffres sont toujours
sujets à caution bien entendu mais ça
mérite quand même qu'on qu'on en débatte
et j'aimerais avoir votre point de vue
sur cette question là deuxè aspect vous
avez été directeur général de
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce et
vous venez d'évoquer les questions de
convergence
élémentaire j'ai toujours été étonné et
beaucoup d'autres bien entendu et
notamment la Confédération européenne du
syndicat sur le fait qu'on acceptait des
pays venir à l'Organisation mondiale du
commerce sans avoir des exigences
élémentaires par rapport à leur
acceptation des critères minimum
déterminé par l'Organisation
internationale du travail ce qui
manifestement a pour conséquence un
dumping social évident et c'était le
sujet à l'ordre du jour de la Haute
Assemblée hier avec une concurrence
déloyal qui va également dans le même
sens donc j'ai toujours été surpris donc
quels ont été les obstacles qui font que
on ne peut pas exiger on est on n pas
exigé tout au moins les normes minimumes
imposées par l'Organisation
internationale du travail avant
d'accepter qu'un pays rejoigne
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce avec
les avantages manifestes que cela avait
3ème point monsieur l'ami je veux
revenir sur les déclarations que vous
avez fait dernièrement indiquant
notamment que euh il était peut-être
utile de mettre en place un SMIC jeune
et donc des petits boulots
entre 2008 et 2011 en pleine période
donc de crise économique financière et
et sociale dans notre pays il faut
savoir que 10 % des plus pauvres ont vu
leur pouvoir d'achat diminuer de 3,4 %
entre 2008 et 2011 dans la même période
les 5 % du plus forttiné de notre pays
ont vu leur pouvoir d'achat croître de
3,5 % je rappeler deux autres chiffres
10 % des plus riches aujourd'hui sur
notre territoire àapare 50 % du
patrimoine national 50 % des moins
fortunés s'en partage 7
% donc la question selon moi qui se pose
une question plus de redistribution
finalement des richesses
globales des efforts partagés entre ceux
qui ont la possibilité de faire des
efforts plutôt que de s'attaquer aux
jeunes qui vont probablement être la
génération de pris l'après guerre qui
risque de vivre moins bien que
l'ensemble des génération qui les ont
précédés et donc plutôt que de demander
des efforts aux jeunes je pense que
d'abord il y a des efforts inter
générationnel qui irit dans un sens
opposé et que par ailleurs il y a bien
d'autres efforts à faire que cela donc
pour tout dire et pour conclure parce
que je sens le Président scientier je le
comprends je je trouve monsieur lami je
le dis en toute
courtoisie V déclarations sur cet aspect
là je pense d'abord que c'est à
l'évidence une mauvaise solution je
trouve ces déclarations un peu
iconoclastes et pour tout dire Laurence
Pariso n'est pas considéré comme étant
une affreuse gauchiste elle même disait
suite aux déclarations de Monsieur Gatas
que baisser le SMIC serait de
l'esclavage donc voilà à un moment où
les profits et les augmentations de des
patrons du C 40 sont
extrêmement sensibles dans cette période
de crise je trouve qu'il était
inconvenant de faire ce genre de
déclaration merci Yannick Monsieur Bruno
rotayo j'ai deux questions à vous poser
la première ça concerne ce que on peut
espérer en terme de croissance
potentielle parce que entre les lignes
vous nous avez donné la définition de ce
qu'on appelle la croissance potentielle
c'est-à-dire le
produit de la démographie active et avec
le progrès autrement dit de façon plus
technocratique la productivité globale
des facteurs ce que on appelle dans
langage courant le le progrès et quand
on a et on fait en France le produit de
ces deux données on n'obtient pas le
chiffre que vous annoncez européen on
obtient moins de 1 % on obtient moins de
1 % c'est à peu près le consensus des
économistes donc on est loin des des
chiffres même que vous sembliez annoncer
euh pour différentes raisons mais je
vous pose cette question est-ce que vous
pensez vraiment que la croissance
potentielle est à 1 et demi pour la
France pour les ou trois prochaines
années oou est-ce que la croissance
potentielle est plutôt à 1 voire 0,8 ou
ou 09 %. c'est important pour un Simp de
débat que que nous avons et notamment
pour la fameuse trajectoire budgétaire
la deuxième
question vous appartenez donc à ces haut
fonctionnaires qui ont sillonné le monde
euh la France sans doute était un peu un
peu lointaine dans dans dans vos
préoccupations du du village glob global
vous avez sûrement lu le dernier livre
d'Hubert Vedrine voyez je choisis mes
mes auteurs et Hubert Vedrine dit à un
moment donné il ne faudrait pas que
l'Europe devienne l'idiot du village
global B
euh je d'ailleurs cette question rejoint
un peu la question sur l'aspect
monétaire que Yan vgenard a appelé il y
a il y a quand même ce qui me choque
bien sûr les théories pour tous ceux qui
ont fait qui se sont et qui se
passionnent toujours pour la science
économique qu' on connaît les théories
ricardiennes mais on sait aussi que
entre la théorie et et la pratique il y
a parfois des béances il y a des
souffrances euh et on doit observer que
mettre en concurrence directe des
populations où les enfants travaille où
on a un quasi esclavage avec des
populations de travailleurs où on a
intégré dieu merci un haut niveau de
protection sociale à un niveau au niveau
de protection environnementale
ça peut peut-être marcher en théorie
mais vous avez en pratique d'énormes
clash alors moi je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec vous sur le fait que la
multiplication des échanges
internationaux je suis passionné par le
numérique donc je sais très bien que ça
crée plus d'interdépendance et je suis
pour cette interdépendance mais il faut
aussi réintroduire un peu de concret un
peu de réel parce que on n'est pas dans
un village virtuel et je je pense que
quand par exemple on va faire on essaie
de faire des efforts c'est plutôt
positifs d'ailleurs globalement pour
réduire le coût du travail en France
mais que en même temps avec le yen
remibi qui est une
monnaie très
sous-évaluée que le dollar est aussi une
sous-évaluée enfin à quoi à quoi servent
nos efforts évidemment dans la zone euro
ça peut fonctionner mais au-delà il y a
il y a cette il y a cet aspect on on a
tous encore à l'esprit ce qui s'est pass
passé pour le photovoltaïque où l'Europe
franchement vis-à-vis de la Chine a
capitulé on a monté les muscles mais on
a capitulé bon bref on sait aussi sur le
dernier Farm Bill américain où la façon
d'aider les agriculteurs désormais passe
par des régimes assurentiels que nous
nous n'avons pas face aux aléas
climatiques qui sont des grands un un
des grands changements mondiaux
aujourd'hui lisz dans le monde hier ce
qui se passe en Floride mais ce qui peut
se passer en vandé avec xintiia c'est la
même chose on sait ce qui se passe d'un
bout à l'autre du monde finalement donc
voilà je je veux tempérer je veux dire
que je je pense qu'il faut travailler
inlassablement sur la réduction d'un
certain nombre d'écarts sur une
convergence réglementaire mais il faut
réintroduire du réel parce que si on
réintroduit pas à un moment donné le
réel et pour reprendre ce que disait
Vedrine on on risque de venir euh avec
des Thor théories extrêmement brillantes
avec beaucoup d'intelligence vraiment
les idiots du village
planétaire merci marine
man plusieurs réactions la première
réaction c'est quel bilan peut-on tirer
de du grand mouvement de libéralisation
mondiale dire est-ce qu'on en fait un un
bilan positif globalement positif ou
est-ce qu'on est capable d'avoir un un
regard critique en disant certes il y a
eu des échanges améliorés il y a eu
l'émergence de certains pays et cetera
et des classe moyenne dans ces pays mais
enfin en même temps j'observe que depuis
qu'il a la libéralisation des mouvements
de capitaux
les paradis fiscaux ne cessent de
croître et embellir et contrairement à
tout ce qu'on raconte ça continue que
par ailleurs les États qui certes
pouvaient avoir des temps des prurites
nationalistes mais qui quand même
incarnaient une certaine souveraineté
populaire nous sommes des républicains
nous croyons à la souveraineté populaire
qu'elle soit française européenne
mondiale enfin on pense que c'est quand
même les peuples qui déterminent leur
leur destin et ben c'est fini puisque
les multinationales N ont vu leur
pouvoir que
ce que les normes internes les normes
internes qu'elles mettent sont parfois
plus importantes que les normes est
dicté par les puissances publiques hein
donc par rapport à cela moi je je
constate quand même que le bilan de
cette libéralisation généralisée n'est
pas positif les inégalités se sont accru
euh au sein des grands pays et et
parfois au des grandes zones comme l'UR
l'Europe euh et je ne vois pas ce qui va
inverser la donne même si je vois avec
bonheur que les Chinois font des grèves
pour avoir de la sécurité sociale et
cetera mais enfinavant que le dernier
des Chinois et des euh des mecs du de
LAF et obtenu un minimum de règles
sociales on a le temps d'avoir perdu
toutes les notes quoi donc euh il y a ce
problème donc moi je pense que le
concept de juste échange euh qui doit
doit être porté au niveau mondial euh
doit trouver des formes de
concrétisation rapide parce que on ne
peut pas nier que les tendances
nationalistes se développent partout en
Inde en Chine en Russie en en Europe et
moi je veux bien votre vision idylique
mais il y a des chocs de l'histoire qui
souvient souvent viennent en écho d'une
incapacité à régler des choses
économiques deuxièmement
l'Europe moi il se trouve que vous le
savez depuis les années 80 je suis
de près ces affaires et je suis une
Européenne
convaincue force de constater plus le
temps va plus le temps
passe plus je suis déçu et plus je
considère qu'on m'a
menti j'ai j'ai écouté le livre blanc ja
de l'or chaque fois on nous promettait
des millions d'emplois d que plus on
libéralisait tout ça allait aller très
bien puis alors quand ça va pas bien
parce que le chômage augmente que les
inégalités entre pays du nord du sud et
cetera se développe on dit on y va pas
encore assez c'est parce qu'on a pas été
au bout de la libéralisation que tout ça
ne marche pas et vous étonnez après que
les peuples ne soient pas motivés sur
les élections européennes et que il ne
croi plus en mais absolument plus dans
les discours qu'on leur vend sur
l'Europe donc par exemple vous
décllarz c'est un problème national
parce qu' il y a des pays qui s'entirent
bien et d'autres qui s'entirent mal et
oui sauf que le cadre qui a été fixé il
est favorable à certains il est
favorable à d'autres alors certes la
France aurait dû réagir avec beaucoup
plus de
véhément sur par exemple le Calc le
système des aides publiques pour les
entreprises mais tout a été fait pour
que la France qui était historiquement
et c'est là où l'Europe il y a la
domination d'un certain nombre de
cultures au détriment d'autres qu'on a
laissé faire le génie français
historique ement c'est quand même du
capital public des aides publiques une
un lien entre l'innovation individuelle
la PME les secteurs industriel le
capitalisme familial et le capitalisme
public et c'est pas pour faire du
Montebourg mais depuis depuis Colbert
plus plus de Gaulle plus mitteran et
puis vous prenez les sondages
aujourd'hui 80 % des Français voudraient
qu'on renationalise Alstom alors moi je
veux bien qu'on soit qu'un pays de
crétin qui rien compris au libéralisme
mais on sait très bien que chaque peuple
a son génie et on a expliqué en Europe
que le génie français était disqualifié
parce que l'idéologie dominante c'était
le libéralisme généralisé et pas d'êre
publique je ne dis pas qu'il fallait
garder les mêmes nationalisations et
cetera mais il fallait avoir une nous
laisser l'espace d'une mutation non
suppression des aides publiques
privatisation
est P entier de l'industrie disparaisse
et après on on dit ah les Allemands sont
géniaux forcément le système est
construit pour
let les favorise bon donc moi je veux
bien ça je constate que les autres pays
d'Europe du Sud sont dans une situation
il y a pas que nous les brêles c'est pas
parce qu' le soleil au sud qu'on est
crrétin et qu'au nord parce qu'ils ont
froid ils sont intelligents parce que je
crois que là ce n'est pas cela donc moi
je ce que je vois c'est quand vous
parlez de la
démographie par exemple quand vous dites
il faut de l'immigration je suis pour
l'immigration je pense qu'un pays qui ne
s'émigre plus ne respire plus truc mais
vous dites il va bien falloir des forces
de travail mais est-ce que la première
priorité ce serait pas de dire que le
plein emploi est un objectif numéro 1
des européen et qu'on se donne les
moyens et que force de constater que les
méthodes qu' on jusqu'à présent été
mises en œuvre n'ont pas permis le plein
emploi je sais bien que les chômeurs
sont tous défeignants qu'on est que des
crétins en France mais enfin il me
semble quand même qu'il y a un problème
sur dernière chose le intuitivement le
modèle que vous prenez celui des
libéraux c'est
chacun va faire ce qu'il est capable de
faire j'attends avant que le nigère se
développe les gars alors heureusement
ils ont de l'uranium et autre mais je ne
crois pas à cela je crois à l'écosystème
humain je ne crois pas qu'il y a dans
une société on doit faire que ce qu'on
est sur quoi on est bon pour être pour
faire on a besoin qu'il y en a qui soi
moins bon autour de soi parce que c'est
aussi ça qui crée de l'innovation quand
vous parlez de la crise de l'innovation
et je ne suis pas d'accord avec
Guillaume Sarkozi vous savait bien que
le patron historique était à l'époque le
patron du textile mais quand ils ont
expliqué les industriels français du
textile que quand on allait délocaliser
le textile une part de l'innovation
allait partir pourquoi parce qu'on ne
sait pas quand on innove si on va
innover sur la fibre sur la manière de
tisser sur la manière de traiter le
tissu comment on introduit dans des
choses vieill comme le monde des
modernités totales et quand on perd la
diversité de ce tissu là on on perd les
capacités d'innovation ou alors on fait
ce qu'on fait en France c'estàdire de la
recherche fondamentale et après quand il
s'agit de penser comment tout ça pe
rentrer dans l'innovation on n arrive
pas donc le modèle de société qui vise à
spécialiser les gens là où ils sont bons
et surtout là où comme le disait ma
collègue à droite tout à l'heure en
discutant là où ils sont le moins chers
et Ben est un modèle suicidaire parce
qu'il ne correspond pas à l'écosystème
humain voilà donc moi je pense que quand
même la remise en cause de de cette
mondialisation et de cette telle qu'elle
est les Français l'ont exprimé à chaque
fois qu'on leur donne la parole il
votent non au traité contre le libre
échange 88 % sont contre le tafta
monsieur uis qui est quand même un
libéral dit lui-même et je termine
là-dessus quand on dit l'Europe elle est
unie quand il s'agit de de d'aller vers
le libéralisme mais pas unie quand il
s'agit de défendre l'intérêt du dernier
des plus faibles des Européens parce que
dans l'accord transatlantique les études
de la Commission européenne montrent que
c seeurs vont être favorisés et d'autres
défavorisés et devinez quels sont les
secteurs qui vont être favorisés la
machine outi allemande et quels sont les
secteurs qui vont être défavorisés
l'agroalimentaire et l'agriculture
française moi je veux bien que ce soit
l'intérêt général de l'Europe mais il y
a pas d'intérêt général de l'Europe qui
sacrifie un bout de l'Europe au profit
d'une autre
merci il nous reste encore tris demandes
de parole après les
deux interventions relativement longues
Monsieur L noir
bien monsieur Président c'est une
invitation à ce que je sois plus court
bien je vais essayer de vous satisfaire
c'est que pour vous c'est un
exercice fa faire des efforts bien
monsieur voudrais d'abord vous poser
deux questions qui en fait des questions
que beaucoup se pose autour de nous
est-ce que vous pouvez confirmer qu'au
fond on est entré dans une phase de
désindustrialisation de la France
beaucoup de personnes autour de nous
disent mais nos industries sont en train
de partirer ce que disait Marie Noël
diman est tout à fait juste quand on
visite des ateliers industriels pas
forcément de très grands ateliers on on
s'intéresse aux machines outil qui sont
utilisé d'où viennent-elles on pose
toujours la question bon rarement la
France on dirit plan machine outil ça
remonte à déjà quelques dizaines
d'années on s'y a cassé les dents mais
est-ce que vous avez pas le sentiment
quand même qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train de faire ce que les Britanniques
ont connu il y a déjà pas mal d'années
bon industrie s'en va au bénéfice du
développement des services sans pour
autant compenser bien sûr les emplois
qui sont détruits et puis de toute façon
est-ce qu'un pays comme le nôtre n'a pas
besoin d'un outil productif que ce soit
d'ailleurs dans le domaine agricole ou
dans le domaine industriel bref est-ce
que cette désinstralisation est pour
vous une évidence est-ce qu'elle est
fatale quels sont quels sont les remède
une deuxième question que que que je me
pose j'ai eu l'occasion lorsque j'étais
débuté de participer à plusieurs sommets
de l'OMC vous étiez vous-même
commissaire européen je me souviens de
Seattle et je me souviens également de
DOA au fond on a l'impression que les
les pays
industrialisés accepte de discuter avec
des pays émergents ça dure des années
des années pendant ce temps-là les pays
émergents s'organise à notre détriment
et puis que finalement on est toujours
un peu en retard on court un peu
derrière et qu'on se fait dans les
discussions menées au plan mondial un
peu àoir c'est un peu l'impression que
que j'ai pu ressentir maintenant deux
questions précises sur sur vous avez dit
vous étiez un homme libre donc je vous
pose des questions sur lesquelles vous
allez pouvoir vous exprimer librement
vous avez raison d'aborder la question
de l'énergie
euh est-ce que vous
considérez que la France commet une
erreur en refusant de regarder ce
qu'elle a sous ses pieds
je pense au gaz de
schiste nous avons entendu en commission
il y a un an et
demi Louis Galois qui avait fixé l'une
de ses priorités qui était le
développement des gaz de chiste j'ai eu
l'occasion de travailler un peu sur
cette question de voir ce qui se passe
aux États-Unis je confirmer votre
diagnosticque je l'ai entendu tout à
l'heure et deuxièmement également dans
le domaine de l'énergie le nucléaire le
nucléaire
bon si on cherche des secteurs où nous
sommes bons
voilà le secteur nucléaire est vraiment
un domaine au moment où on parle
dalstom qu'est- quel est quel est un peu
votre point de vue sur cette question et
avec une question subsidiaire est-ce que
vous croyez possible à ce que l'Europe
est une politique de l'énergie pour ma
part je ne le crois pas chacun fait en
fonction de ses moyens et les politiques
qui sont menées me paraissent
complètement contradictoires hein mais
bon enfin un dernier point sur lequel
vous allez pouvoir vous livrer comme
vous le pensez la présédente majorité
sur l'impulsion du Président de la
République avait voté la TVR sociale
quelle est votre opinion sur ce qui
avait été voté mis en place qui a été
ensuite Ôé est-ce que c'est un moyen de
faire face à la concurrence des pays
émergeant merci Monsieur leoir très bien
euh vous président un vra compliment
monsieur Claude dy
oui merci monsieur le Président ce sera
une question simple et je pense rapide
même si quand on commence comme ça c'est
mauvais signe mais là je vais essayer de
oui je je la question monsieur l'ami est
dans la suite de de vos propos sur la
nécessité de convergence vous avez parlé
de de convergence réglementaire
concernant la sécurité sanitaire et
cetera euh yannick vugrenard a parlé
aussi de convergence en ce qui concerne
le droit du travail qui me paraît
effectivement des choses tout à fait
souhaitable si on veut organiser pour ne
pas dire réguler le le commerce
international en tous les cas le rendre
plus juste euh est-ce que vous pensez
que le moment n'est pas venu de
s'occuper aussi des atteintes graves euh
à l'environnement car euh là aussi ça
peut provoquer des distension de
distorsion de concurrence je je suis pas
tout à fait enfin c'est pas la même
chose que ce que vient de dire monsieur
Lenoir mais effectivement euh l'énergie
est importante et le coût de l'énergie
est important euh dans la compétitivité
alors quand on a des modes d'extraction
non conventionnel des carburants
manifestement ça revient moins cher mais
manifestement aussi enfin moi je suis
pas spécialiste ça peut provoquer des
dégâts sur l'environnement qui sont
importants de même que le traitement des
déchets je parle pas seulement des
déchets nucléaire c'est pas peut-être le
plus important effectivement mais de
tous les déchets coûtent cher et donc il
faudrait pas donner une prime à ceux
qui ne prennent pas en compte cet aspect
là alors on me dira bon B le gaz de
schiste c'est chez chez nous mais enfin
on sait très bien que on le sait très
bien depuis Tchernobyl que les atintes
graves à l'environnement ne s'arrêtent
pas aux frontières des uns et des autres
donc il me semble que peut-être là on
devrait commencer à prendre des mesures
en terme de d'organisation du commerce
mondial merci Madame René niikou oui je
seraai brève aussi mais je voulais
aborder la question des de la
législation qui et et des législations
qui sont qui font partie de des
discussions sur l'accord de partenariat
transatlantique il est question que ces
législations en vigueur des deux côtés
de l'Atlantique se pie aux normes du
libre échange et que lorsqu'il y a une
entrave ou lorsqu'il y a une directive
prise par un gouvernement une
réglementation qui viendrait entraver le
bon fonctionnement d'une entreprise ou
limiter ses ses gains c'est la
législation en vigueur
permettrait d'obtenir des compensations
de la part de ces gouvernements est-ce
que ça n'est pas là une une entrave à la
bonne gestion à la bonne gouvernance de
chaque pays
et une fin à la libre administration des
pays et au profit du libre
échange merci Monsieur l'ami vous avez
seul la parole de
renavant Monsieur L noir faites pas de
provocation
rapidement euh sur euh la question de la
monnaie je n'ai pas euh à la différence
de ce que je dirais tout à l'heure sur
le gaz de chiste la même position que
Louis Gallois
euh ces affaires de taux de change
doivent être regardé avec les bons
chiffres et pas avec les chiffres de la
veille ou du lendemain euh qui sont les
taux nominaux euh de changes nominaux
qu'on constate sur les marchés ce qui
importe euh pour la compétitivité des
économies à moyen long terme
euh c'est ce qu'on appelle le taux de
change effectif réel c'est-à-dire le
taux de change corriger des effets de
prix et pondérer euh en fonction de la
nature des flux commerciaux auxquels ces
taux de change s'appliquent
donc c'est ça le bon chiffre qu'il faut
regarder c'est quelque chose qu'on ne
fait hélas pas souvent et si vous
regardez le taux d'change effectif réel
euro doollar il est stable sur 20 ou 30
ans et donc cette idée selon laquelle
c'est l'euro le problème à mon avis ne
tient pas si on regarde les chiffres euh
deuxièmement euh je rappelle que c'est
pas la Banque centrale européenne qui a
la responsabilité de la politique de
change dans les traités européens c'est
le Conseil des ministres même si une
politique monétaire a des effets induits
sur le change en fonction des taux
d'intérêt et troisièmement je ne suis
pas de ceux qui brandissent comme c'est
souvent le cas dans notre hexagone chéri
qui brandissent la dépréciation et la
dévaluation comme la solution miracle à
tous nos mots comme si la dépréciation
d'une monnaie voir sa dévaluation
n'avait pas des effets
négatifs hein c'est vrai que ça peut
être bien pour la compétibilité
exportateurs mais c'est nettement moins
bien pour la
compétitivité de ceux qui importe hein
que vous gagnez d'un côté vous le perdez
de l'autre et au fur et à mesure que le
contenu en valeur
ajoutée de vos exportations en
importationug
cet effet finit par finit par
s'équilibrer et
donc ne pensons pas si ça devait être
une tentation que l'impact économique et
social d'une dépréciation ou d'une
dévaluation de la monnaie ne fait pas un
choc sur l'économie et ne remet pas en
cause la compétitivité d'un certain
nombre d'acteurs de notre économie et
notamment et notamment sur un continent
et dans un pays qui pour les raisons que
j'ai indiqué tout à l'heure doit
importer énormément
d'énergie donc à mon avis l'euro n'est
pas le problème essentiel si l'euro
était le problème si l'euro doollar
était le problème essentiel et j'
reviendrai l'Union européenne n'aurait
pas un surplu industriel de 300
milliards d'euros par
an si vous regardez le cas de la France
où la France perd-elle départ de marché
c'est sur la zone euro là où la monnaie
est unique où est-ce qu'elle se
débrouille plutôt pas mal c'est hors
zone euro là où on n'est pas dans la
même zone monétaire donc regardons les
chiffres aussi humblement que possible
et ceci me dit en gros que le problème
européen et français n'est pas d'ordre
monétaire sur les normes sociales
internationales vous avez tout à fait
raison d'ailleurs quand j'étais
commissaire européen j'étais porteur
d'un mandat qui consistait à disons
établir un pont un peu plus un peu moins
pointillé qu'il ne l'est entre
l'Organisation internationale du travail
et l'internation naationale du commerce
je l'ai fait quand j'étais dég de l'OMC
du point de vue de ce que je pouvais
faire c'està-dire de ce que je pouvais
faire sans que mon conseil général qui
représente tous les membres de
l'OMC ne me remonte les bretelles la
vérité
euh toute crue c'est que le système
international est ainsi fait que les
États décident à
l'OMC les critères
de la régulation du commerce
international et il décide à l'OIT les
critères de la régulation des standards
sociaux et il décide à l'Union
internationale des télécommunications la
répartition internationale des
fréquences et il décide au Codex
alimentarus qui est une filiale de
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé et
de la FAO de un certain nombre de
standards pour la sécurité des aliments
c'est comme ça nous vivons dans ce
système depuis
1648 les porteurs de la cohérence
entre par exemple les règles du commerce
et les règles sociales ce sont 200 état
nation
souverain et lorsque 200 état nation
souverain ce qui pas forcément tout le
enfin disons en gros souscrivent à des
engagement et à des disciplines en
matière de standards sociaux ils doivent
les
respecter simplement ça n'est pas une
affaire qui est traitée du côté
commercial c'est une affaire qui est
traitée du côté social l'OIT a son mon
propre mécanisme de règlement des
différent Leit peut autoriser des
sanctions sur des pays qui ne respectent
pas les standards sociaux simplement
pour des raisons diverses qui tiennent à
l'équilibre des forces à l'intérieur de
l'OIT par le mandat qui a été donné au
directeur général de l'oï il y a 30 ans
de mettre en place un mécanisme de
règlement des différents sérieux n'a
jamais été exercé parce que il n'y a pas
disons la volonté politique chez les
membres de l'OIT d'aller jusque là hein
donc faut pas mettre ça sur le dos de
l'OMC ou de l'OIT d'ailleurs c'est de la
responsabilité des États nation
souverains qui composent ces
organisations ce que peuvent faire les
exécutifs et je crois que j'y ai
participé et que c'est reconnu y compris
par un certain nombre de forces
syndicales mondiales j'ai été le premier
à bâtir des ponts à peu près sérieux sur
le plan des études sur le plan du
travail commun entre l'OMC et l'IT mais
disons euh dans la limite de ce que les
Indiens d'un côté et les Américains de
l'autre côté euh considéraent devait
être pe-être la ligne jaune sur les
petits boulots je je n'y reviens pas je
je répète que je suis un homme libre et
que mes propos n'engagent que moi euh et
donc ça j'espère que ça limite euh la
portée euh de ces propos mais en même
temps euh euh parce que je suis libre je
dis ce que je pense euh et pour moi il
s'agit pas de demander des efforts aux
jeunes en terme de d'augmentation des
inégalités il s'agit euh de trouver du
boulot pour les jeunes
point barre je n'aurais jamais dit ce
que j'ai dit si on avait un taux de
chômage des jeunes de 5 ou 10 % comme en
Suisse ou en Allemagne jamais je
n'aurais dit ça à 25 % de chômage des
jeunes je pense que nous sommes dans une
zone rouge et que quand on est dans une
zone rouge il faut remettre en cause
quelques lignes
jaunes aussi simple que ça je ne vous
demande pas de partager ce point de vue
je vous explique simplement l'ind tion
qui est la mienne quand je vois que mon
pays tolère 25 % de chômage des
jeunes voilà c'est une
indignation j'ai été j'ai participé au
Gouvernement de la République comme vous
le savez dans les années 80 8 80 à 85 au
côté de Jacques Delor à l'époque le
problème de la France cétait
l'inflation j'étais et je reste membre
du parti
socialiste l'indexation des salaires
était une conquête sociale je me suis
battu avec du côté des salariés quand
j'étais j'ai mé syndicaliste à un moment
je trouvais à l'époque que l'indexation
des salaires était une conquête sociale
qui permettait de préserver le pouvoir
d'achat des salariés jusqu'au jour où on
a eu une inflation de 15 % et où on
s'est aperçu que ça ne pouvait pas
tenir qu'est-ce qu'on a fait on a un
gouvernement de gauche le premier depuis
très longtemps dans la République
française a remis en cause l'indexation
des salaires sur les prix on a remis en
cause une conquête sociale au bénéfice
des
salariés les salariés ont bénéficié de
la désindexation des salaires sur les
prix et de temps en temps il faut
accepter à mon avis d'envisager les
choses sous un autre angle parce que
sinon on reste en
calaminé chez moi en Normandie je
connais des gamins qu' ont 15 ans et
dont les parents ont jamais eu de boulot
hein et ça pour moi c'est
l'horreur l'horreur hein et je pense et
je pense et je pense que je pas que
c'est une solution miracle je dis pas
que c'est quelque chose de je je dis pas
que quelque chose d'éternel mais je
pense que la priorité c'est d'ailleurs
ce qu'on fait beaucoup d'autres
pays regardons un peu ce que font les
autres regardons pourquoi chez eux le
taux de chômage des jeunes est moins
fort que acceptons de temps en temps que
malgré le génie français de Marie Noël à
laquelle auquel je vais revenir bien
entendu que malgré le génie français il
y a des pays qui ont connu des problèmes
similaires au nôtres et qui ont trouvé
des solution hein donc la question c'est
pas est-ce qu'il y a les solutions oui
il y a des solutions la question c'est
pourquoi on s'engage pas dans ces
solutions mais encore une fois je je
c'est quelque chose qui que je ressens
fortement et sans doute effectivement la
pratique que j'ai eu consiste à regarder
comment font les autres m'a sûrement
imbibé
davantage sur le sur le cas français
population productivité disons taux de
croissance potentielle de la
France effectivement disons la mauvaise
nouvelle c'est que vous avez
probablement raison dans le cas français
on est probablement un peu au-dessous de
ce potentiel européen la bonne nouvelle
c'est que la raison pour laquelle on est
un peu au-dessous n'est pas d'ordre
démographique au contraire de ce point
de vue-là on se présente plutôt bien
c'est du côté de la productivité bon or
la productivité ça se change mieux plus
vite et plus facilement que la
démographie bon mais ça c'est la bonne
nouvelle parce que on a une faiblesse là
où d'un certain point de
vue le potentiel d'action est le plus
fort bon moi quand je suis dans une
situation comme ça je suis
content voilà bon alors j'y viens j'y
viens
j'y viens mais disons c'est vraiment une
affaire de productivité hein et et et et
de compétitivité prix et de
compétitivité hors prix et nous savons
ce qu'il en est Galois a tout dit et
très bien sur cette question et si ça
suffit pas il suffit de de prendre ce
que le Commissariat général au Plan à la
stratégie écrit qui à mon avis est très
bonne qualité y compris sur des points
sur lesquels je je suis pas forcément
d'accord bien donc c'est là il y a une
opportunité pour la France hein le fait
que son potentiel soit plus bas si on
regarde les raisons pour lesquelles il
est plus bas alors c'est pas forcément
une mauvaise nouvelle sur l'idiot du
village global
euh je ne partage pas le point de vue de
Hubert qui le sait d'ailleurs depuis
longtemps sur les questions européennes
Hubert est un neurosceptique de talent
je suis un poste national poussif c'est
comme ça nous nous en débattons sur
diverses tribunes il se trouve que son
bouquin est sorti 3 semaines avant le
mien euh on part à peu près du même
endroit on arrive à peu près au même
endroit simplement c'est vrai que
l'itinéraire entre les deux n'est pas
forcément le même aucun chiffre aucun
chiffre ne vient à l'appui de cette
légende française ou disons que partage
certains chez nous selon laquelle
l'Europe sera l'idiot du village global
aucun chiffre un idiot du village global
qui a 300 milliards d'euros d'excédent
industriel moi je veux bien être idiot
tous les jours à ce prix-là hein ça ça
ne fait pas de sens toutes les analyses
qui ont été faites de la politique
commerciale l'Union européenne et
l'Union européenne comme d'autres doit
passer chez le docteur OMC une fois tous
les 2 3 ans pour un checkup complet qui
fait l'objet d'un rapport public avec
des chiffres publiques et une discussion
publique l'Europe ne se protège ni mieux
ni moins bien que des animaux
comparables il n'y a aucune faiblesse
structurel dans la politique commerciale
de l'Union donc cette idée pour moi
d'ailleurs elle est elle est très
révélatrice de cette capacité que nous
avons de temps en temps à nous
autolagéler à dire vraiment on est
vraiment très mauvais on est les idiots
du village global c'est forcément c'est
pas comme ça qu'on
mobilise les troupes et je pense que
c'est une
erreur factuelle et de temps en temps il
faut regarder les faittes et pas
seulement les idées les doctrines les
discours
et ça ne correspond pas à la réalité sur
la Chine est-ce que le Red minbi est
sous-évalué non il l' plus hein c'est ce
que nous dit le FMI qui est qui est
disons le grand arbitre des beautés en
matière de taux de
change le FMI le le le Ren minbi en taux
de change constant effectif réel s
réévalué de 25 % au cours des 10
dernières années à court terme c'est
vrai ils ont un peu
décroché mais mais et ils savent très
bien qu'ils n'internationaliseront pas
leur monnaie ce qui est leur objectif
géostratégique en en ayant une monnaie
faible il est vrai que le compte de
capital de la Chine n'est pas libéralisé
il y a pas besoin d'être libéralisé
d'avoir un compte de capital libéralisé
pour appartenir au FMI aussi étrange que
ça puisse paraître d'ailleurs c'est
comme ça les règles internationales sont
ce qu'elles sont aussi longtemps qu'on
ne leschange pas elles sont ce qu'elles
sont quant au salair chinois ils font
c'est vrai qu'ils augmentent de 15 % par
an et Marie Noë a raison de dire que la
bonne nouvelle de temps en temps c'est
que les Chinois font grève et donc petit
à petit petit à petit l'excédent
commercial chinois se réduit au fur à
mesure que la consommation intérieure
prend le relais de la croissance
chinoise sur le sur le farmbill
américain
euh je suis pas en état parce que j'ai
plus les moyens l'armée technique que
j'avais quand j'étais déj de l'OMC euh à
ma connaissance la question de la
compatibilité du farmob américain avec
les règles existantes à l'OMC en matière
de
subvention n'a pas été examiné hein donc
je sais pas si a priori on peut dire que
ça colle ou que ça colle pas il faut
regarder dans le détail mais évidemment
c'est évidemment quelque chose qui devra
faire l'objet d'un examen à
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce
éventuellement d'ailleurs pourquoi pas
l'initiative de l'Union
européenne qui disons de temps en temps
un peu pas forcément la première à
soulever les questions de soutien à
l'activité agricole dans le cadre et
dans l'enceinte de l'Organisation
mondiale du commerce pour des raisons
qu'on comprend bien bon Marie Noë on va
pas se lancer dans un grand débat
public ce que tu appelles libéralisation
j'appelle ouverture des échanges et et
c'est une nuance sémantique importante
hein ouverture ouvrir c'est ouvrir
libéraliser au sens de déréguler c'est
autre chose hein et là il y a des
petites confusions sémantiques
auxquelles il faut faire attention en
gros l'ouverture des échanges a donné de
très bons résultat les économies
ouvertes marchent mieux que les
économies fermées ce qui s'est passé
depuis 30 ans a formidablement réduit la
pauvreté dans le monde il est vrai au
prix de la croissance d'inégalité à
l'intérieur des pays c'est le point de
vue que je développe dans la première
partie de ce petit livre où je parle de
la mondialisation Janus et là c'est bon
côté et là c'est mauvais côté je n'ai
d'ailleurs jamais été un avocat de je ne
sais trop quelle mondialisation
paradisiaque ou heureuse euh euh il y a
des forces en sens contraire il y a des
courants il y a des vents et puis il
faut savoir les prendre à la fin du fin
c'est c'est décision humaine il n'y a
pas de
facilité et donc il est vrai que le
rapport entre disons l'économie les
marchés et les sociétés et notamment les
sociétés politiques et remis en cause
par cette phase là de globalisation
comme il l'a d'ailleurs par les phases
de globalisation précédentees
euh il y a un sujet difficile
d'articulation entre de désencastrement
comme disait Polan entre entre
l'économie et la société au niveau
mondial je suis de ceux qui pensent
qu'il y a des solutions à ce problème et
notamment que les systèmes qui offrent
davantage de solidarité sociale que les
autres sont meilleur pour traiter cette
question c'est pas un hasard si les pays
les plus compétitifs sur cette planète
sur le moy moyen long terme sont ceux
qui ont les systèmes sociaux les plus
sophistiqués il y a d'autres facteurs
qui interviennent mais celui-là
intervient certainement quant au juste
échange 100 fois pour comme je l'écrit
d'ailleurs dans ce petit livre à une
condition c'est que les partenaires à
l'échange se mettent d'accord sur ce qui
est
juste ce qui en gros nous ramène à la
case départ hein c'est un concept
formidable sauf que si on doit discuter
tous les deux de ce qu'est le juste
échange faudra commencer par se mettre
d'accord sur ce qui est juste ce qui
suppose d'un certain point de vue le
problème
résolu et donc on en est on on en est on
en est pas là quant au raisonnement sur
l'Europe cadre favorable aux autres et
pas à nous typique de cette
autolagellation française qui consiste à
penser qu'on est des mauvais qu'on est
des médiocres qu'on se fait avoir par
les autres et quand c'est pas la Chine
c'est la Allemagne et quand c'est pas
l'Allemagne c'est Bruxelles et quand
c'est pas Bruxelles c'est les immigrés
quand c'est pas les immigrés c'est les
Arabes il y a toujours il y a toujours
une raison extérieure à nos problèmes
l'Allemagne et j'ai connu ça quand
j'étais à Bruxelles après la
réunification a connu des années
épouvantables l'Allemagne était l'homme
malade de l'Europe dans la même Europe
que nous elle était malade plus
rienallait comme chez nous et puis
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont pas
changé l'Europe pour ça ils ont fait une
opération qui s'appelle stand
Deutschland ils ont pris le taureau par
les cornes et ils ont petit à petit
réussi à résoudre un certain nombre de
leurs problèmes donc avec le même cadre
l'Allemagne est sorti de la Moïse alors
que nous n'en sommes pas sortis donc ça
n'est pas ça n'est pas l'Europe qui est
responsable nous
avons nous
avons s'il vous plaît monsieur rotot pas
de provocation
mais nous avons nous avons nous avons
nos propres problèmes reconnaissons-le
et ne mettons pas ces problèmes toujours
sur le dos encore une fois de cette
mondialisation de la Chine de
l'Allemagne de Bruxelles aussi longtemps
aussi longtemps que nous resterons dans
cet état
d'esprit qui consiste à attribuer
l'essentiel de nos problèmes ailleurs ce
qui commode
intellectuellement notre pays continuera
la dérive qu'il a entamé il y a 40 ans
avec le déficite des finances public
qu'il a entamé il y a 30 ans avec le
chômage de masse et qu'il a entamé il y
a 10 ans avec la détérioration de sa
compétitivitéess on peut faire les deux
on peut
l'essentiel l'essentiel de nos problèmes
est chez nous et je dénonce je regrette
pour ma part cette tendance que je
constate dans notre pays à mettre la
racine de nos problèmes sur le dos des
autres je pense que c'est une attitude
intellectuelle erronée et que quand on a
une attitude intellectuelle erronée on
n'agit pas dans le bon sens quant au
génie français il est là il n'a rien de
disqualifier il doit au contraire
s'employer et s'engager je vais euh dans
quelques minutes remettre à Monsieur
Jean-Pascal triquir le prix du financier
de l'année voilà une entreprise schned
électrique qui a pas toujours connu
disons un dessin industriel formidable
si on song à ce que fut
cosoloir voilà une entreprise
mondialisée qui fait
915 % de son chiffre d'affaires hors de
France qui est un succès formidable qui
est dans un métier d'avenir qui est
positionné sur les marchés émergents
typique du génie français bien que
Jean-Pascal tricoir ne soit pas un
produit de l'élite des grandes écoles ce
qui est peut-être d'ailleurs une des
raisons des raisons pour lesqu
absolument et et voilà un vandéen qui
vient à Hong Kong alors je je je je sais
bien je sais bien qu'un vendéen qui vit
à Hong Kong ça dérange chez nous mais
c'est une des raisons principales de son
succès et donc il y a il y a manière de
réussir et d'accord avec Marie Noël pour
que c'est un écosystème encore une fois
ne restons pas sur des formules quel est
le bon niveau d'appréhension de cet
écosystème aussi longtemps qu'on n pas
répondu à cette question on n pas
beaucoup avancé sur la désinstralisation
bien sûr une
désinralisation mais l'essentiel vient
des marges insuffisantes des entreprises
françaises
nont pas de marge suffisante ne font pas
assez de profit hein c'est quand un
social-démocrate parle de profit ici
c'est toujours dangereux mais la vérité
économique c'est que les marges des
entreprises françaises sont
insuffisantes qu'elles n'ont pas de quoi
investir et donc qu'un certain nombre
d'activités euh se font ailleurs euh il
n'y a là-dedans rien de Fatal hein et
regardez le ce qu'on fait les
Britanniques hein les Britanniques
étaient euh des mauvais dans l'industrie
il y a 20 ans et et nous on était des
bons
la part de PNB provenant de l'industrie
est plus forte en grandbretagne chez eux
qu'elle ne l'ai chez nous bien donc rien
de Fatal mais mais mais si les marges de
entreprises restent ce qu'elles sont
alors notre tissu entrepreneurial et
c'est vrai dans l'industrie comme dans
les services sauf que l'industrie est
par nature plus exposée à la concurrence
internationale hein ai 60 % de notre
économie c'est des services 40 % c'est
autre chose l'industrie étant plus
exposé à la concurrence internationale
la faiblesse de ses marges la fragilise
davantage du point de vue de la
poursuite des activité et de la
compétitivité que ça n'est le cas dans
les services sur G de 6 je ne sais pas
j'ai tendance à à partager la position
de Louis Gallois mais disons je ne sais
pas et au fond on donne pas les moyens
de savoir exact
bon bien donc je ne sais pas et je n'ai
pas les moyens de savoir je peux peux
pas dire
plus euh sur le nucléaire je crois qu'on
ne peut pas se passer du nucléaire euh
accessoirement c'est une énergie qui
émet relativement moins de CO2 même si
on prend l'intégralité de la chaîne je
pense que c'est un avantage comparatif
et ça doit faire partie du mix
énergétique français d'accord avec vous
pour dire que au niveau européen les
politiques il n'y a pas aujourd'hui de
politique énergétique européenne que
c'est le bazar et à mon avis c'est trop
le bazar il y a forcément des des
différences mais elles sont aujourd'hui
excessives et là c'est une question de
volonté politique y compris de la part
de la Commission européenne qui devrait
savoir de temps en temps euh mettre sur
la table euh des projets de décision à
faire euh décider à la majorité qualifié
sur ces sujets hein ce que ce qu'elle
n'a pas fait sur la TVA sociale euh j'ai
sociale ou pas euh la question c'est de
savoir si une Haos de la TVA euh est une
bonne solution hein c'est pas qu'elle
soit sociale ou pas sociale c'est
toujours la même c'est toujours la mme
après après après la question c'est
est-ce que vous faites peser sur le
consommateur davantage du poids du du
coût du système de redistribution c'est
ça la question bien he le consommateur
va payer la TVA pas me dire que c'est
pas le consommateur qui paye la TVA al
non mais le consommateur va payer
davantage de TVA donc c'est un problème
qui se pose pas seulement pour la TVA
sociale est-ce que on doit faire
porter le poids du financement de la
redistribuation française que ce soit
par l'État les collectivités locales ou
que ce soit par des régimes sociaux
est-ce qu'on doit le faire porter
davantage sur le consommateur moi j'ai
tendance à penser queoui parce que je
pense que c'est quelque chose à moyen
long terme qui est de nature à nous
aider à redresser notre compétitivité
hein c'est ce que je pense mais de là à
faire une recommandation en disant de
combien de points et ce qu'on retire
d'ailleurs pour la rajouter là je n'en
sait rien mais si vousoulez c'est ça ça
n'a de sens qu'à l'intérieur de d' d'un
concept général qui est sur quel acteur
économique le financement de notre
système de redistribution doit-il peser
sur l'environnement entièrement d'accord
il y a évidemment une question
importante qui est celle de l'empreinte
environnementale de de nos systèmes de
production et on sait bien qu'elle est
pas soutenable à terme de 20 30 ou 40
ans
euh on sait bien que l'énergie la
consommation d'énergie mais pas
seulement d'énergie aussi d'eau par
exemple est est un des problèm et ça
c'est soit vous régulez ça de manière
multilatérale c'est le sens des
négociations internationales sur
changement climatique qui piétinent
depuis 12 ou 20 ans soit vous le réglez
de manière unilatérale du type je prends
une mesure à la frontière qui est
destinée à équilibrer l'empreinte
carbone de mes importations avec
l'emprunte de carbone de ma production
domestique dans le cas européen
malheureusement ça ne marche pas pour
une raison simple c'est que l'empreunte
carbone des exportations européennes est
plus mauvaise que celle des importations
européennes contrairement à ce que
beaucoup de gens
pense l'Europe globalement est
spécialisée dans le commerce Inter
international dans des industries dans
des secteurs qui sont très carbonés on a
parlé de la machine outil deux fois ce
ce matin on voilà un excellent exemple
il y a pas plus carboné qu'une machine
outil même chose pour l'automobile même
chose pour les assets spéciaux et donc
si vous faites le
bilan commerce extérieur européen en
terme de carbone et que vous allez dans
cette direction en gros la seule
conclusion logique que vous pouvez tirer
c'est que vous devez subventionner les
importations européennes ce qui est
assez
contreintuitif bon mais encore une fois
pour aller dans cette direction il faut
regarder les chiffres de temps en temps
et savoir où on met les pieds la la voie
royale reste une solution globale et
j'espère qu'on j'espère qu'on oui
j'espère qu'on finira par la trouver
sans sans je de mot euh madame
euh ni coup bon sur le sur les
négociations transatlantiques je crois
que j'ai expliqué en gros quel é le
contexte hein il s'agit de
négocier de la convergence réglementaire
avec toutes les difficultés que ça
présente et toutes les opportunités que
ça présente sur l'affaire du mécanisme
de règlement des
différents qui est effectivement sur la
table de la négociation à la demande des
Américains qui est ce qu'on appelle
investor to state dispute settlement qui
est un système de règlement de
contentieux qui permet contrairement à
ce qui se passe par exemple à l'OMC ou
conformément à ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur des pays à une
entreprise d'attaquer un
souverain lorsque l'entreprise considère
que le non respect par ce souverain des
dispositions de l'accord crée un dommage
au détriment de
l'entreprise donc une procédure
spéciale que les Américains en général
mettent dans leurs traités
bilatéraux mon sentiment mais encore une
fois qui n'engage que moi je suis
mandaté par personne sur cette affaire
c'est que je vois bien l'intérêt d'un
mécanisme de ce genre si l'Europe doit
assigner un traité de libre échange avec
le Sri Lanka le Népal ou la Birmanie
parce que je j'auris pas forcément
tendance à faire confiance à la justice
birman népalaise ou sri-lancaise si je
suis investisseur là-bas et que j'ai un
sérieux problème donc l'idée d'avoir un
dispositif juridictionnel
séparé me paraît disons assez justifié
si je suis investisseur et que je veux
que s'il y a un contentieux sur mes
activités et mon investissement ce soit
soit fait selon les règles normales du
droit bon dans le cas euroaméricain j'ai
tendance à penser que même s'il est
compliqué le système judiciaire
juridique américain et en gros de
qualité standard et que le système
euréen judiciaire est en gros de qualité
standard les entreprises européennes
peuvent attaquer le gouvernement
américain sur l'espace américain les
entreprises américaines peuvent attaquer
les gouvernements enfin les entités
souveraines européennes sur l'espace
européen donc a priori je ne vois pas
disons la
l'utilité vois pas l'utilité a priori je
ne vois pas l'utilité d'un mécanisme de
ce genre autrement dit je pense que les
européens peuvent faire confiance à la
justice américaine s'il y a un litige et
que les Américains peuvent faire
confiance à la justice européenne
elles ont bonne réputation elles sont
parfois un peu compliquées mais elles
ont en tout cas pas la réputation de
prendre des décisions dans le sens de
celui qui donne la plus grosse enveloppe
donc voilà ma voilà ma position sur ce
sujet merci je vous remercie d'avoir
passé plus d'une heure et demi avec nous
et permettre ces échanges en tous les
cas même si si sur un certain nombre de
points nous avons j'ai bien compris
quelques différences
d'approche c'est toujours intéressant
d'avoir le point de vue
complémentaire Marie Noël s'est enrichi
ce matin je suis persuadé
donc conforté surpris surpris bien je
vous remerci moi je jeunes c'est un
chiffre sur les jeunes sur le marché si
tu rapportes à la classe d'âge tu te
rendras compte que le chômage des jeunes
en France est plutôt dans la moyenne
base de l'Union européenne parce que
nous avons beaucoup de gens scolarisés
longtemps alors après on peut dire
est-ce qu'ils sont tous bien scolarisés
où il font non mais je m'excuse mais
c'est plutôt c'est plutôt quand même
positif que le niveau scolaire des trucs
je ne veux pas dire que le chômage des
jeunes n'est pas un problème ah bon et
ben ben au moins sur ce point on est
d'accord et j'espère qu'on est d'accord
sur le fait que c'est un énorme problème
plus d' problème bien sûr mais je ne
crois absolument pas la solution non
mais la théorie la France ser
auut Marie Noël je je compare aux autres
c'est tout voilà pour cette audition de
Pascal lami qui a été pendant 10 ans
directeur général de l'OMC
l'Organisation mondiale du commerce et
qui était auditionné en tant que
président d'honneur du laboratoire
d'idée notre Europe institut Jacques
Delor vous pouvez bien sûr toujours voir
et revoir toutes les auditions sur notre
site sur
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire 16h30 cet
après-midi pour 20 4h Sénat la séance
présentée par dphine Girard très bonne
journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires